I'm shubra I run product marketing and
developer relations are joined and I'd
be joined by quite a few developers wife
sure friends Wyatt is my colleague is a
lead node.js engineer and he has been
active contributor to different
frameworks like happy Seneca and you
know even toward the micro services that
we run ourselves at joined and even
myself I have been in the Express
community and I've worked on through
your frameworks like loopback
and API gateways right so just to give
you a context so the workshop today is
going to be focused on building an IOT
app and we'll be using a variety of
technologies I'll walk you to that stack
but before I do that you know want to
put a disclaimer we are not going to be
talking any proprietary or closed source
products at joint ourselves we have been
the progenitor of node we are kind of
the first incubate node.js and we are
also the founding member of C and C F
and we believe that the entire cloud and
all the technologies running within it
should be in the open right and we are
entirely community driven so with that I
want to you know give you our point of
view on how we see the legacy stack and
the modern stack and this is based on
people we are working in the community
our customers as well so if you look at
the legacy stack right these were
traditionally monolithic web apps and
we're running code on different kind of
blocking and bloated platforms right you
could say JIT JVM CLRS what they were
and traditionally these were deployed in
virtual machines right if you go back
like 10 years and running inside a
private data center now if you flip the
stack like when you talk about
modernization the app services are more
message driven there are more micro
services they are built for mobile first
right you don't really build for you
know they are build responsive they are
not just built for the web you're
building them for IOT workloads as well
as artificial intelligence workloads
right and we can go to dirt I'm just
gonna skim through a lot of these topics
from a coding perspective
you know you'd see the rise of nodejs
golang and a lot of different light
weight runtime platforms or languages
the whole idea is like can you support
concurrency can they work with async
workloads right and from a runtime
perspective you know if you take the
case of micro services there's a perfect
fit where you want to run them on
containers you would take the case
instance of nodejs
most of the processes are running single
threaded running then more traditional
VM is probably an overkill so you
probably want to just package it run it
you know in package it in an immutable
fashion push it to the cloud run it on a
lightweight container right and the
infrastructure supporting that is you
know that's kind of you know I don't
have to preach on that that's
essentially cloud right now but there
are differences in the cloud right so
some of the projects we work on and
we'll be discussing these in the
framework of this workshop if you look
at node we work on a node core justify
these rst pfizer framework D traces
essentially a universal debugging tool
that you can use in production happy you
know it's another API framework MDB was
again for memory leak debugging we are
also going to talk about Express gateway
which was recently launched as recent as
last week and again we have been
investing we are polyglot ourselves we
are not a hundred percent node shop so
if you look at tooling and like projects
that we are working and particularly in
the golang community these are around
terraform around you know particularly
for provisioning our containers for
console for service management vault for
security Prometheus for monitoring
Packer and crypto and other core
libraries and on the container side you
know we started with continuous ten
years back right we were running
infrastructure of bare metal containers
and then we put a docker but we had to
make it run in production not like a
Mickey Mouse like standalone project so
we created the concept of an elastic
docker host where we stack the entire
data center into a single docker host
with a single docker API endpoint and
you can just push based on a compose
file or any artifact you have you can
essentially push your applique
blueprint and get it deployed in a
matter of minutes and obviously we work
on kubernetes and we have also created a
micro app orchestration framework called
as container pilot we are going to be
using container pilot today right
and finally on the cloud you know
obviously our because our in that cloud
is hundred percent open-source we
operate our public clouds but most of
our users also deployed on-premises
in their own private cloud managed
private cloud settings and it's
primarily due to cost and performance so
let's go into the details so there's a
github link if you want to grab that URL
I'll be on this slide for a few seconds
that's as all the contents of the code
and the exercises says github.com Joya
slash joint slash summit workshop just a
show of hands if anybody was not able to
get that all right there are some
prerequisites for this workshop will be
primarily be using node.js so you'll
have to install node.js if you haven't
already you should while I'm and you can
do that like when I'm walking through
the rest of the slides you need to at
least have a local docker install I
think those are the primary prereqs
and optional you know if you really want
to push this out like once you test it
on your laptop if you want to push this
out into a public cloud you can
essentially sign up for joints public
cloud we have 250 dollars free credits
and we won't be charging anything for
the workshop right so you but again
that's optional if you really want to
test it out like how it works in the
cloud make sense so I'll just hang on to
this slide for another few seconds so
that you have the URLs
perfect all right so what are we going
to build today we are going to build an
IOT app it's a highly distributed micro
service app we'll have a variety of
endpoints that will consume data from so
you know we'll be using sensor data and
out of the sensor data we'll be using a
home automation platform called as smart
things and smart things you know selves
use sensors for you know motion sensors
humidity sensors whatnot and once we get
all that data will be monitoring the
data feed that is coming in will be
storing that into a database that's
where we will use influx DB and we'll
also gather some monitoring data for
using agents like Prometheus and then we
have a variety of other components you
know including an API gateway including
Redis and then we will all of these
services that are interconnected with
each other or each of them is running on
a container of its own and we will
orchestrate this and we will scale it
out right so we'll start from scratch
build you know test integrate deploy and
scale
okay so just few of the technology
stacks that we'll be covering today
right if you want to take a picture you
could so at the very top right because
we are consuming data from a smart thing
sensor and like we are not going to use
real smart things we are going to
simulate that data right but it's kind
of the same experience if you had to get
it from a real home automation system
right to protect all this api's we are
going to use a front-end component call
as the express gateway and I will get
into the details of that this project
was launched last week and we have elf
on from the Gateway team just say he's
your hands so you know if you have
follow-up questions you can reach out to
him on the Express gateway we also have
al al sang from the Express gate waiting
so you know they are here to help and
again with me I have Wyatt and we have
Colin is our hands and we have fires as
well so if you have any node questions
or container question
you know reach out obviously we'll use
node will be using frameworks like happy
and Seneca Seneca is a microservices
framework all written in node.js from a
back-end perspective like from the
front-end essentially we have Prometheus
endpoints and on the backend we'll be
using in floods DB to store time series
data and from a container perspective
we'll be running
traditional docker however to wire our
entire application blueprint and to
deploy it and scale it will be using
container pilot and finally you know the
option where we push it to the public
cloud will be using try to it from joint
so when I get into all of these let's
quickly run through some of these key
concepts right I just showed you a bunch
of technology and then we'll start
really working the exercises so just
architectural eHow is smart things laid
out right so it has a bunch of sensors
and if like every you know IOT home
device manufacturer this is not like
industrial IOT this is a really home
automation you have a hub right and the
traditional way these connects there are
a variety of protocols that are ZigBee
protocols and whatnot where in all of
these devices that are present at your
home they connect to a hub right and
based on those connect and connection
endpoints then you essentially have
device handlers and then you send up the
data through an API gateway and that API
gateway is consuming your events data
and pushing it to a cloud processing
system and on the cloud side and this
cloud could be running anywhere
traditionally it's a public cloud you
have a set of core api's which lets you
not just monitor the data but if you
have to take actions on your devices
okay I have a thermostat which is
reporting 75 degree Fahrenheit and I
have to control it down to push it down
to like 70 or maybe I have like a
Philips hue bulb right which I want to
bill so there's an action that you need
to take and that API call comes through
an API gateway and then the API gateway
communicates the same to your local hub
which is sitting at the edge and then
the edge hub translates the protocol and
then sends out the control logic
to the device that you want to control
right so this is a very high level
architecture so that's one component
that we are going to use the second
component is we talked about the Express
gateway so show our fans who has use
Express Jas
pretty much everyone right so brand-new
gateway at some API gateway which was
built on top of Express was launched at
a meet-up last week and highly
successful and like all the cool
contributors of express like that Wilson
and everybody is behind it even from a
joint perspective we are of started
pushing PRS and we are actively
contributing to it right and you have
Al's company lunch badger who is kind of
the core maintainer and net net if you
are really looking at you know what does
the Gateway do right you have a set of
end points that you are protecting so
there are functions like authentication
authorization right you do use a variety
of tokens and then you have to configure
policies right so when the API scums
they come in you said you define a
policies a set of policies which are
applied on the pipeline of API calls
coming in and if you start going beyond
that then you have to really talk about
role based access control like you know
all these API is what kind of
permissioning you have right is it
read/write update all the current
permissions and then when you start
going beyond that then you start about
go around metering right so if you're
still you know putting an API gate to in
front of your API service you can
actually meter the calls and you can
extend this to charge back you can use
extended to throttle right saying hey
you know what this is one public API
endpoint and I don't want you know all
of these internet population hitting
this endpoint maybe I can create on the
load-balanced one right so you can check
this out and not go into a lot of
details into this because we have a lot
of ground to cover but this is one of
the key components that will be using
microservices you know we are here to
build micro services just show our fans
you must build a micro service running
in production okay a few of them but so
you know I don't need to be preaching to
the choir but essentially you know this
is a very simple visual representation
of what I said earlier
you had a set of monolithic services I
had written monolithic services myself
traditional SOA architectures where you
add an orchestration bus and you had
Mirim endpoints right these were
essentially web service calls that you
were making but again they were like
they were packaged they were not
essentially like you didn't have a
particular service endpoint for a
particular small API call where you
could just manage the whole lifecycle so
if that endpoint went down right you
didn't really you know we could just
work on it and bring that back again
you essentially had to work you know
recovering the entire SOA tier right so
these micro services you know right now
the way you build it you know there are
different variety of frameworks out
there but once you start scaling these
micro services you know particularly on
the container platforms there are
frameworks like kubernetes any
kubernetes users here this one okay so
there are frameworks kubernetes came out
of Google there's you know docker swarm
there's Miso's where you essentially can
orchestrate right how you deploy these
and how do you scale these on containers
right and this is a brand new stack
right it's not on VMs and you know these
containers you know you could be scaling
but it's not just scaling horizontally
you have to account for what happens if
around managing the lifecycle of a micro
service so we'll talk about that in a
bit so this is a layout of our own cloud
so joints entire cloud is built in micro
services we did it like eight years back
when nobody knew the term micro services
we were built on Ruby on Rails so all of
the ones that you see in green right
whether it's actually at our external
endpoint whether it's in our middleware
or internal services or where we
actually go ahead and access data we
have object storage at the backend all
of these are a set of API s and each API
is managed by a standalone developer and
a standalone team who can essentially
manage the lifecycle and all the way
from development to build to deploy to
scale and everything else right and we
chose node.js and that was one of our
primary drivers why we you know
contributed and sponsored the project to
use something for ourselves and then
caught on in the community and outs in
the foundation cool another thing that's
really coming to forte is going
container native right so if you deploy
containers on traditional VMs right it's
really a workaround
that's not how containers were designed
to run and that's not what will give you
the efficiency of containers right so
the stack that you see on the left is
traditionally what most enterprises are
doing today whether it's on-prem or it's
in the public clouds and the reason is
there's a lot of technical debt you had
created your data centers and your
clouds based on VMs and you couldn't
really run containers directly on bare
metal you could but on static bare-metal
but then you didn't have the flexibility
of like how do you do cloud management
and scheduling and all those features
right if you really start going into
container native and not just us there
are other companies who are doing this
as well instead of doing hardware
virtualization using kvms
we are going to doing West
virtualization so we are essentially
running a docker shim very close to the
kernel and we don't need any of the bin
packaging libraries that or any of the
overhead that you need for VMs and we
are running that the docker app directly
on that right cool another project that
we are going to use today is the
framework call as container pilot this
is you know you can works with any
scheduler if you're using swarm
kubernetes or our Triton normies O's but
this lets you do micro orchestration so
I will tell you what that means
so when you you know create a bunch of
micro services you know it's not just
start and stop right how and
particularly when you are running these
micro services in containers how do you
manage the lifecycle events so do you
have you know health checks going into
micro service how do you know when there
is an event maybe there is a error or
you know how do you handle that error
how do you gracefully start it up and
how do you gracefully stop it how do you
understand the events when you know that
particular micro service is choking and
you need to provision more and scale out
right so here's a very simple example
with my sequel right it's a relational
database you'd be using this in most
projects very very virally used
however it like in production he doesn't
want to be running one instance you want
to be continuously snapshot in your data
and backing it up to some kind of an
object general object storage so in our
in this case what we are doing is we
have one primary node and two replicas
nodes and we are continuously backing
that data from the primary internal node
to our manta which is essentially our
object storage solution and you could do
this on any cloud in s3 but then those
replica nodes you know we do a sync
replicate replication right and you can
set this up on your own now and on what
we are doing is console we are using it
as a service discovery tool right so
when a client comes in and it goes to
query it doesn't really go directly to
the node it goes on queries console and
says hey consult by the way if you don't
know console it's a tool from Hoshi Corp
you know similar tools are like at CD
where you would use them in service
management but console would say hey I
have these three endpoints which are
like all my sequel this one is the
primary like throughout the traffic
there right so where you can see here
that the call comes to from console to
the primary and you're doing heartbeats
so you are checking hey primary are you
append kicking right and as long as
that's true that traffic will be routed
there now let's assume that the primary
goes down right and at that time you
have a boot sequence which says hey you
know boot from replica but when that
boot from replica happens console needs
to be updated automatically saying hey
now read out the traffic and get the
data from the replica set and when and
then I have to make those replicas aware
and pooling hey does the as the primary
come back again right so to do this you
can use you know this is an entire
pattern that has been created for
application level micro orchestration so
this one essentially is doing monitoring
right so the way we work is there are
different type of events there's a you
know periodic health check but you
essentially whenever you provision a
micro service you register the micro
service so there's a registration event
you register that into console and
during the health checks you are saying
hey are you the primary yes I am
should I just backup my data they said
no you know I'm still in
processing transactions don't do it or
yeah maybe go ahead and do it and you
know continuously tell I'm healthy I am
healthy I am healthy now if something
goes down the system has to self-heal
right all these micro services should be
self-healing because there are going to
be thousands of micro services when you
eventually go into the enterprise you
cannot do manual type processing like
you do it for our traditional SOA based
services so what you could do is you
know on the deven that you see hey there
was a change right and on the change
what we said okay if the primary sends
me a change event maybe it went down
first thing you do is stop replication
right don't replicate anymore because
I'll be sending corrupt data into my
backup and at that time look at me and
the primary right or should I just you
know give up my lock or should I still
retain my lock so you know you are down
so we let the replica attain the lock
and let that serve up right and now if
I'm saying okay I am back up again you
know go ahead and retake the lock right
but when you do this you have to
propagate the changes upstream to your
load balancer and to your service
catalog so when we actually use this in
context of the code that you are going
to write today you'll see this how
helpful it is and how simple it's going
to manage so with that being said I'm
going to turn it over to Wyatt to walk
you through the exercises and I'm
assuming by this time you have node and
a local copy of docker install anybody
who has not been successful doing that
yet okay and we are here to have you
know so we'll be walking around the
floor Thank You Shiba let me plug in
here so you all have a V clone the repo
cool so if you look on the readme it'll
if you look on the readme it lists the
different challenges the first two are
really geared to make sure that you have
note installed correctly and then the
second one is for docker so I think
we'll probably spend about five minutes
on each of those first exercises so if
you if you look at the readme
we're just trying to spin up a simple
node application so the challenge is to
start it with a port and in this case
port 8080 which will be provided through
an environment variable and once you
have that up and running you'll you'll
be able to go to your browser and see a
chart with random data being displayed
and if you have any questions feel free
to raise your hand and we'll bring over
a mic or just one of us will come and
help you out there's also a solution
file in each of the challenges that
explains the solution so the pace of
this will go like we'll spend five
minutes on this first one and then I'll
show you the solution and then we'll go
to the next challenge
and so forth but we want to keep this
pretty laid-back so again just raise
your hand if you have a question or if
you get stuck so I'm going to go ahead
and walk through the solution to the
first one it's okay if you didn't
complete it because the remainder of the
exercises are all using docker that was
more of a test to make sure you have
note installed and know how environment
variables work so let's see here if I go
into I'm gonna make that larger for you
they go into the challenge 1 folder so I
have my let's see how to dice up
so I had already npm installed
everything before I came here so I have
that shortcut for me and then you can
set environment variables just by
prepending whatever you want before you
run a node so in this case I'm going to
listen on port 8080 and if you go into
your browser you'll see let's see this
8080 you should see a front-end with
this random sensor data and this is
pretty much what we're going to see
throughout the remainder of the
exercises so while this will actually
work with a smartthings hub we don't
have a smart thing stub here especially
for this many attendees and also the
sensor data from like the real
temperature data is kind of boring
this is a little bit more exciting at
least so anyway that's the solution of
the first challenge npm install and then
start node so the next challenge is
using docker which is a little bit more
fun so we want to let's go back to the
challenge here so the next one we're
going to docker eyes that front end so
this is just using that same front-end
that we had running it inside of a
docker container and listening on a port
again this will hopefully prove that you
have docker installed correctly so again
we'll give you say five minutes to work
through challenge two and then I'll
present the solution and if you get
stuck just raise your hand
how's everybody doing with a challenge
is the network any better no well once
you get that note Alpine image that
should speed up the next challenge
hopefully so anyway let's walk through
the solution here for challenge - so
you're supposed to update the dockerfile
so in this case we're building from an
Alpine distro of node which is actually
the smallest one that you can find so I
did that hopeful hoping that the network
wouldn't be this slow but apparently it
is so typically with your docker file
and node you're gonna copy over all your
resources so your package your j/s files
and then you'll need to run npm install
so if you look in the solution here send
a copy from that so we'll run npm
install and you can see above this we
had already established that the working
directory is where our app was copied to
and then i'm this on a run node period
or node index or npm start however you
want to start up your node process so
that'll create the image that we need
but we also needed the the port for the
environment variable and that comes
whenever we're actually only get into
the raid folder and that comes whenever
we're actually starting the container so
i'll build the image which is super fast
cuz I already have everything downloaded
and be cached and then you can run that
image as a container so I'm going to set
the environment variable with that e - E
and - P is published so I'm gonna map
the docker host port 8080 externally and
then I'm going to give it a friendly
name front end so that is now running if
I run docker PS I can see so I have that
image running and port 8080 is
mapped so again if I go to localhost
8080 I should see the same front-end
that I saw whenever I had just node
running locally okay so also in the
solution it includes how to remove that
so if you do docker RM that removes a
container if you want to remove an image
it's RMI so docker RM remove the
front-end so that's great
pretty simple hopefully you all didn't
get too stuck on the docker part so
let's move on to challenge 3 where we're
actually adding another container into
the mix and for that we're going to use
docker compose and we're also going to
add in the Express gateway which we've
been talking about so the challenge here
is to add to update the Express gateway
configuration to point to the two
instances of the front end that we now
have in the compose file so if you look
in challenge 3 docker compose you can
see that we are creating two front ends
by having two different services front
end one and front end two so we need to
update the links for the Gateway so that
it has the correct IP addresses mapped
inside of the Gateway that represent the
front end one in front and two and then
in gateway we have this configuration
amyl file that you'll need to update
with the the server and port for the
front and one in front end - and since
you're using links in this example links
will update the host file inside the
container with like a front end one and
then the IP of whatever that was started
as okay so give you five minutes on this
challenge and then I'll walk through the
solution so you're going to use a
different command all
so docker compose instead of just docker
cool
all right well let you get to it and
again if you have any express gateway
questions we have a couple of experts
here so feel free to raise your hands
all right I'm gonna walk through the
solution it seems like things have sped
up a little bit which is good so let's
see first I'll update the links so just
head front end one and front end two so
that'll add a new Etsy house entry for
front end one with the IP address in the
in the Gateway container and if I go
into here I can change the URLs so this
will the Express gateway will load
balance these two for me so see GP and
then the server will be front end one
and then 80 80 80 80 and then it's going
to the right folder challenge three
and then it'll every time you refresh on
the on a DAT
it'll be load balance to either the
front end one or front end two and it'll
just serve up either of those whatever
you get at the time also I wanted to
remind everybody that oh I don't know if
you were reminded of this at all but
there's t-shirts up here and stickers
popcorn
come on up feel free to grab some yeah
you can come up anytime we have all
sizes men's and women's help yourself
so yeah you have to at least have
completed challenge three by now though
so there you go
your size right now we'll have more
tomorrow at the giant booth out front so
come on by if you wanted a second shirt
or whatever fits
so links is nice whenever you're doing
local development but when you're
actually trying to scale to more than
just a couple of instances it's not not
really a sustainable solution
so as shubra was talking about earlier
we have container pilot which takes out
the issue of having to have a load
balancer in between all of your services
and relies on console which is a service
discovery catalog and we'll use that
we'll use console to discover you know
what services are up and healthy and
that's how we'll discover the front-end
instances so this next challenge is just
to rely on the container pilot
configuration to update the
configuration let me show you that see
so if you look in the Gateway folder we
have an Etsy we have this JSON 5 file
which is just a very JavaScript friendly
way to do JSON it just looks like
JavaScript but anyway this is how we
control container pilot so we describe
what processes we want container pilot
to start up and in this case it's the
Gateway and since we're listening on a
port container pilot will register the
Gateway with console for us and it'll
start our server so a good way to think
about container pilot is just a really
useful container init process so you
have like tiny and dominat already that
are made for running in containers for
doing a net work container pilot is no
different except it adds in the extra
service discovery and health checking
that you'd want to have so your
challenge is to update the container
pilot JSON 5 file here to add in a job
to run this binary which gets copied
which generates the
and finds the frontend addresses for you
so yeah and if you look in the readme
there's also links for the container
pilot documentation but anyway I'll give
you say ten minutes but your main goal
is just to add another job here and then
spin it up and you should be able to go
to port 8500 to see consul and you
should also be able to scale the number
of front-end instances you have to
whatever number you want and it'll
automatically update the gateway and the
Gateway will load balance everything for
you so 10 to 15 minutes and feel free to
agrees your hand if you have any
questions so I'm going to go ahead and
jump to the solution on challenge for
mainly because challenge 5 is much
larger and requires a few other images
and/or it our internet is not the
fastest so let me go ahead and do that
so you were supposed to add in a new job
to run the generate config for you
whenever you're starting up so you could
do it just like this which would work
but ideally you would also add in this
extra part which tells the Gateway not
to even start until after I've been able
to see until after this pre start job is
successful so we won't even start the
server until we actually have some front
ends to balance to and then we already
had a watch down here so anytime so this
last job let me explain that sorry the
last job explained or will run anytime
there's a change with the front end so
if there's a change in the front end
inside of console like you added more
instances or one of them became
unhealthy then the Gateway will be
notified about that and will execute
this on
frontend job which will just regenerate
the configuration for us which was not
entirely necessary for the challenge but
it's good just have that kind of
responsiveness built in so if we start
it all up we should just have one
instance of the front end and let me
show you I don't know did you all go to
console here on port 8500 if you didn't
this is what it'll look like here when
it loads
so we have console registered here than
the front end with to help passing
checks and then the Gateway and we can
go to the gateway which is listening on
port 8080 and we just have that one
front end that's balanced but you can
also scale the front end to say three
instances so we'll create two more
instances of the front end and those
whenever they're healthy we'll register
inside of console so if we refresh
console here you can see now we have six
passing health checks for each of the
instances and then the gateway would
have been notified that there's a change
in console and reran that generate
config which went out to console and
grabbed all the healthy addresses so now
if you refresh the front-end you should
get balanced to another back-end and so
on and so forth so the next challenge
really builds on this and adds the other
services that we actually care about so
that the the dummy data has not just
coming from the front end it's actually
coming from a serializer which pulls the
data from a worker which then pulls it
from the smartthings hub so we'll just
move on to challenge five which is a
little bit more involved let's see a
little so there's two parts to this
you're supposed to update the sensor so
if you look in the folder here for
challenge 5 you know have see the front
end we have the serializer and then that
sensor which is the worker that pulls
data from Nats which is a message
queuing service and pushes it to the
serializer so your job is to update at
the bottom here we have this right data
function so use the module called
piloted which will talk to console for
you and we'll handle that change event
automat
so add in here something that uses
piloted that pulls down the serializer
address and then also you need to update
the container pilot configuration for
the sensor so that it has the on change
for the serializer plugged into it and
since this involves a few more images I
think it's probably going to take
another 20 minutes or so but this
challenge really encompasses I think a
lot of what we're going for in the
overall workshop so I'm gonna give you
more time on that and again if you get
stuck feel free to raise your hand or if
you just have any general questions also
raise your hand so I realized I left you
kind of hanging on what pilot it is or
why do you even use it sorry about that
so pilot it is just a module that will
do the load balancing for you inside of
your service since we don't have any
load balancer that we're going through
we need some way to distribute you know
our requests and and so pilot it has a
pretty simple API you can do piloted
service and just the name of the service
that you care to get so in this case the
serializer and it'll bring back the next
healthy address for you for the
serializer or so in this case yeah will
do serializer equals that so serializer
in this case we'll have the address and
port from console of the next healthy
instance of the serializer
because we can scale to multiple
instances now if we want and the nice
thing about this is we actually since we
don't have a load balancer we can tell
if there are any healthy serializers at
all so if there aren't any serializers
we can do what you're supposed to do in
a micro service which is be able to you
know respond to failure so in this case
let's say we don't have any serializers
I could return early and maybe try this
again in like a second
so I don't know set timeout and then
write data this is of course in a
consume more memory but it'll work
yeah
so that's the example there I think
that's right so then the other part of
the challenge again was just to update
the the container pilot config which
I'll leave you to that and downloading
the images but any questions on pilot it
or why you'd use it or does that explain
it ok cool so I'll show you the rest of
the solution and save five minutes does
that sound good to everybody I'm going
to show you the solution to challenge
five here and then I'm going to go
through the next two exercises since
we're low on time and just show you
those solutions as well which builds on
what we already have here and then I'm
going to hand it back over to shubra to
close it out so let's see so we already
have the serializer update done and I
was talking to Colin back there and he
was pointing out that this is probably
not a good solution because it's going
to buffer up the data in memory and
eventually probably exhaust exhaust your
memory so says since it is since your
data and you probably don't care about
it so much you could just return early
and be done with it the other part of
this was to update the container pilot
configuration so that it responds
anytime there's a serializer change in
console and the way we do that I'm just
and I copy from the solution file so
we'll create another job let's go back
so we need to create another job similar
to what we have here for Nats which says
anytime there's a change to the
serializer we're going to send a signal
to node and that'll not restart the
process but it'll just send that signal
and then piloted will handle it and go
out and fetch an updated list of healthy
addresses from console because something
change
changed and the other part was to add
the actual watcher so container pilot
will use these watches to just query
console for changes to serializer or
Nats so that allows us to let me go to
the right folder here that allows us to
spin up new instances of serializer or
tear them down and the sensor will be
able to handle those changes which is
very powerful okay so you can do docker
compose up mm-hmm I think I have my
previous one still running so kill
everything bring it up with the
alright kind of kill that
Challenge for
so this is a good good habit make sure
you remove everything from the current
challenge before moving on to the next
one just what I failed to do there so
challenge five doctor compose up - D so
there's quite a few more images in this
one we have influx Nats
if we go back to the front end again we
can see in this case since we don't have
all the workers running we should just
see the temperature data coming in wait
for that to load and also if we look at
console now we have more services that
are registered so now we have smart
things Nats so yeah we have the
temperature sensor done because we have
that worker added the next challenge
would be to add the other workers so
humidity and motion and the way you do
that is to update the compose file so if
you look down here we have temperature
which is using that sensors folder so we
can change this to humidity so at a new
service named humidity and we just say
the sensor type is humidity and it will
start subscribing to the nets message
queue for any humidity messages and
it'll report those into the serializer
so if I do up again since I just added
humidity give it a second here actually
let me go to the next challenge since
it'll be cached
you bring it all down
so the next challenge would just add
those two and then you'd see the data
flowing but it's just essentially just
copying and pasting from the temperature
docker compose service here so the last
challenge which is what I'm going to
show now is adding in telemetry
reporting so container pilot in addition
to using console for service discovery
also has telemetry support for
Prometheus so you can add in any metrics
that you carried a report on so if you
looked at challenge seven say the front
end you should see there's like a memory
script here which will report on how
much free memory is inside the front end
container and if you look at the
configuration for that we now have this
telemetry entry so this will listen for
on port 1990 and Prometheus will know
that there's telemetry data because
we're registered inside of console we
have a new entry for container pilot and
then Prometheus goes out and pulls all
these metrics down and we'll report on
them so I want to show what that looks
like which is actually pretty powerful
mainly because it's so flexible yeah
I'll just do that
so again if you refresh console you'll
now see Prometheus whenever it comes
along so it might be the last to come up
and then Prometheus listens on port 9090
and then you have these custom metrics
that we've just added so the free memory
you can report on that and again this is
completely dependent on whatever you
want to report through Prometheus and
then if you scaled out the front end you
would see more instances shown so scale
friend say - and then if you refresh or
execute that graph again you'll see more
metrics coming through for each instance
so that's that's what I have for the
workshop I know we didn't get through
everything but again you can take this
home and and play around with it all the
codes their solutions are all there and
I also wanted to point out so you can
deploy this to Triton
if you want in that final section and we
also have another working example of
this so if you go to github slash
autopilot pattern we have tons of
examples of using container Pilate for
solving the same type of problem but for
other things like my sequel as shubra
was pointing out we have Jenkins
we have WordPress but we also have
another node example which is very
similar to this one and it has a nice
setup script and walks you through
deploying everything - Triton if you
want to so that's what I have and I'm
gonna hand it back over to soubrette
and close this out and I'll be here
throughout the week if you want to chat
about any any of these topics or
anything else thank you
[Applause]
all right folks I'm gonna wrap this up
but that being said I think you were
working towards different exercises and
you have deployed it locally to your
docket environment I'm gonna try and
give you a quick overview of how we have
architected Triton so that if you want
to push it to a real cloud and run it
for yourself you can so essentially like
when we built write it right we build it
as a next generation of cloud and there
are different ways you can run it right
you can essentially build your own cloud
your way with essentially open source
software right so you can run it public
you can write it private you can run
different hybrid modes but there are
three key components to it right there
is compute and when we say compute this
is essentially containers on bare metal
and different containers like and I'll
go through that and then there is object
storage that project is called Manta so
if you go to github so you know
github.com slash joint slash Triton
that's essentially your compute and if
you go to storage or analytics go to
github.com slash joint slash Manta those
two are the storage and conversion
analytics and converge analytics is a
special project because if you really
think of it right generally when people
store object data somewhere and then you
are running like Big Data jobs on that
you essentially have to copy data or the
network so whenever you are accounting
for latency you have to take into
account the time it takes to move data
over and particularly if you are
operating at petabyte exabyte level
scale that's extremely time consuming so
I'll tell you a little bit more it
architecture it but here's essentially a
system architecture like how you can
build your own cloud right so at the bar
at the very lower end you will see the
infrastructure which essentially is
elastic bare metal what this really
means its voice level virtualization
instead of hardware virtualization and
on top of it you are either running
elastic docker host or you are running
traditional VMs right and even VMs we
essentially use KVM so you can bring
your own KBM and then you can run any
image on top right
you're really a window shop you can run
Windows on there but if you're running
darker you can run Drock or directly on
the elastic docker host or you can bring
a scheduler like kubernetes and make it
work with that and so there are three
different ways to run containers right
so it's not like you know when you start
speaking with other developers and ask
them like what are you using to run
micro services and containers like how
do you decide the first one that you see
here kubernetes I have asked that in
like DevOps conferences and show of
hands like who's using kubernetes and
80% of them raised their hand that's
like why right oh because you know my
coworker told me to write you really
need to take a pragmatic approach and
say hey you know what are the use cases
behind it right if you are building a
micro services application just like you
were building now and you had a few
endpoints right how many endpoints did
you have like 10 12
those were the rest API endpoints start
thinking about a large enterprise on a
larger scale application where maybe you
have a thousand endpoints and each of
those endpoints need to run on a
container each right and you need to
orchestrate the material time that for
that kind of a heavy lifting
I would think kubernetes type of a
framework is a great fit but if you
really want to run one container right
having a small monolithic app or maybe
ten containers I think it's simply an
overkill right or maybe you want to run
stateful apps right data bases or
wherever you are caring about transient
State and you know persistence I don't
think kubernetes has yet nailed that
right so that's where we kind of went
category by category right so we created
elastic docker host which is essentially
great for if you're running you can run
both stateful and stateless but it's
really when you looked at container
pilot with some of the use cases we
talked about with my sequel we are
essentially dealing with persistent
state right which you cannot do with a
framework like kubernetes but if you
really don't are really you know
scratching the surface here and all you
really care about is cost savings and
performance you can just run
in metal but with the cloud filled
flexibility right so that's where we
have brought in this concept of
infrastructure containers has anybody
heard the term infrastructure container
before this earlier
just one guy yeah so if you have to do a
little bit of reading right go search up
Alexis wait Aleksey containers or just
pure infrastructure containers this
didn't like docker didn't or containers
didn't really arrive with docker in 2013
2014 people were doing containers like
way back in 2006 and we originally used
a project called open Solaris which was
derived from alumnus to build those but
then there are the Linux guys who have
been using LXE containers to primarily
achieve the same thing right you can
have containers run them just like a
virtualized infrastructure but you run
them on bare metal without having to you
know take the overhead of all the
hardware virtualization and the bin
packaging so another great project to
look at I talked about Manta when we get
converged analytics so you can really
store data at scale so joint like we got
acquired by Samsung and just as a use
case right we are hosting all of Samsung
Mobile's back-end data and if you have
to get some context how much how big
that data looks like it's in exabytes a
year right
think about 250 million concurrent users
pushing images videos whatnot through
their phones and we are essentially
asking ourselves to handle that data
right so on a highly distributed open
source object storage system
so that's object storage but what we
have done is a few years back when we
ran this on a file system we use ZFS as
the underlying flight sis file system
and we were able to spin up a container
in place where the object data resided
so when you spin up a container what you
can actually do with it is run a
computer right so hey I want to run our
big data analytics right so let's say I
have a MapReduce job I want to run a
maybe I want to do log processing or
search text right just query the day
how do I do that right so if you just
wanted to transport the rate hey I had
these image files I want to create
thumbnails of that or run any kind of
arbitrary compute so because we spun up
that container zone we're right where
the object data was you can essentially
run converged analytics without having
to move the data anywhere and when we
did this we essentially followed the
UNIX Bible and said hey if you run unix
commands you can write your own computer
beYOU don't really have to learn a
framework you could write your own
computer bin awk right in Perl or shell
or any other language you can bring
other languages but it's not framework
dependent right and so I would highly
encourage you to go to github check that
out
github.com /join slash manta and net net
right with all these projects what we
are really trying to build at the end of
the day and we have built it ourselves
we are trying to share this for the
community is essentially build open and
portable services right which don't have
to be locked in into a particular
framework a particular cloud or
particular orchestration framework so
these are some of the sample projects
that got built with container pilots so
why it was just walking you through the
github repo so check it out it's
actually very simple to build self
managing and self-healing application
patterns using this microservices and
net net I want to end by saying you know
our goal is essentially to give the
cloud back to the people and democratize
the system and that's why we are here so
you know we'll be at the booth and the
rest of the conference swing by our boot
talk to us and you know if you have not
got any schwag you know feel free to
grab them and what to call out the
Express gateway guys one more time al
sang a need form and thanks :
and what & Fire's for showing up and
helping thank you
[Applause]